We will now study a problem
which is quite difficult to
approach in a direct brute
force manner but becomes
tractable once we break it down
into simpler pieces using
several of the tricks that
we have learned so far.
And this problem will also
be a good opportunity for
reviewing some of the tricks
and techniques
that we have developed.
The problem is the following.
There are n people.
And let's say for the purpose of
illustration that we have 3
people, persons 1, 2, and 3.
And each person has a hat.
They throw their hats
inside a box.
And then each person picks a hat
at random out of that box.
So here are the three parts.
And one possible outcome of this
experiment is that person
1 ends up with hat number 2,
person 2 ends up with hat
number 1, person 3 ends
up with hat number 3.
We could indicate the hats that
each person got by noting
here the numbers associated
with each
person, the hat numbers.
And notice that this sequence
of numbers, which is a
description of the outcome of
the experiment, is just a
permutation of the numbers
1, 2, 3 of the hats.
So we permute the hat numbers so
that we can place them next
to the person that got
each one of the hats.
In particular, we have n
factorial possible outcomes.
This is the number of possible
permutations.
What does it mean to pick
hats at random?
One interpretation
is that every
permutation is equally likely.
And since we have n factorial
permutations, each permutation
would have a probability
of 1 over n factorial.
But there's another way of
describing our model, which is
the following.
Person 1 gets a hat at random
out of the three available.
Then person 2 gets a hat
at random out of
the remaining hats.
Then person 3 gets the
remaining hat.
Each time that there is a
choice, each one of the
available hats is equally
likely to be picked
as any other hat.
Let us calculate the
probability, let's say, that
this particular permutation
gets materialized.
The probability that person 1
gets hat number 2 is 1/3.
Then we're left with two hats.
Person 2 has 2 hats
to choose from.
The probability that it picks
this particular hat
is going to be 1/2.
And finally, person 3 has only 1
hat available, so it will be
picked with probability 1.
So the probability of this
particular permutation is one
over 3 factorial.
But you can repeat this argument
and consider any
other permutation, and you will
always be getting the
same answer.
Any particular permutation has
the same probability, one over
3 factorial.
The same argument goes through
for the case of general n, n
people and n hats.
And we will find that any
permutation will have the same
probability, 1/n factorial.
Therefore, the process of
picking one hat at a time is
probabilistically identical to
a model in which we simply
state that all permutations
are equally likely.
Now that we have described our
model and our process and the
associated probabilities, let
us consider the question we
want to answer.
Let X be the number of people
who get their own hat back.
For example, for the outcome
that we have drawn here, the
only person who gets their
own hat back is person 3.
And so in this case X happens
to take the value of 1.
What we want to do is to
calculate the expected value
of the random variable X. The
problem is difficult because
if you try to calculate the PMF
of the random variable X
and then use the definition of
the expectation to calculate
this sum, you will run into
big difficulties.
Calculating this quantity, the
PMF of X, is difficult.
And it is difficult because
there is no simple expression
that describes it.
So we need to do something more
intelligent, find some
other way of approaching
the problem.
The trick that we will use is to
employ indicator variables.
Let Xi be equal to one 1 if
person i selects their own hat
and 0 otherwise.
So then, each one of the Xi's
is 1 whenever a person has
selected their own hat.
And by adding all the 1's that
we may get, we obtain the
total number of people who have
selected their own hats.
This makes things easier,
because now to calculate the
expected value of X it's
sufficient to calculate the
expected value of each one of
those terms and add the
expected values, which
we're allowed to
do because of linearity.
So let's look at the
typical term here.
What is the expected
value of Xi?
If you consider the first
description or our model, all
permutations are equally likely,
this description is
symmetric with respect to
all of the persons.
So the expected value of Xi
should be the same as the
expected value of X1.
Now, to calculate the expected
value of X1, we will consider
the sequential description of
the process in which 1 is the
first person to pick a hat.
Now, since X1 is a Bernoulli
random variable that takes
values 0 or 1, the expected
value of X1 is just the
probability that X1
is equal to 1.
And if person 1 is the first
one to choose a hat, that
person has probability 1/n of
obtaining the correct hat.
So each one of these random
variables has an expected
value of 1/n.
The expected value of X by
linearity is going to be the
sum of the expected values.
There is n of them.
Each expected value is 1/n.
And so the final answer is 1.
This is the expected value
of the random variable X.
Let us now move and try to
calculate a more difficult
quantity, namely, the variance
of X. How shall we proceed?
Things would be easiest if the
random variables Xi were
independent.
Because in that case, the
variance of X would be the sum
of the variances of the Xi's.
But are the Xi's independent?
Let us consider a
special case.
Suppose that we only have two
persons and that I tell you
that the first person got
their own hat back.
In that case, the second person
must have also gotten
their own hat back.
If, on the other hand, person 1
did not to get their own hat
back, then person 2 will not get
their own hat back either.
Because in this scenario, person
1 gets hat 2, and that
means that person
2 gets hat 1.
So we see that knowing the value
of the random variable
X1 tells us a lot about
the value of the
random variable X2.
And that means that the
random variables
X1 and X2 are dependent.
More generally, if I were to
tell you that the first n
minus 1 people got their own
hats back, then the last
remaining person will have
his or her own hat
available to be picked.
That's going to be the
only available hat.
And then person n we also
get their hat back.
So we see that the information
about some of the Xi's gives
us information about
the remaining Xn.
And again, this means
that the random
variables are dependent.
Since we do not have
independence, we cannot find
the variance by just adding the
variances of the different
random variables.
But we need to do a lot more
work in that direction.
In general, whenever we need to
calculate variances, it is
usually simpler to carry out
the calculation using this
alternative form for
the variance.
So let us start towards a
calculation of the expected
value of X squared.
Now the random variable X
squared, by simple algebra, is
this expression times itself.
And by expanding the
product we get all
sorts of cross terms.
Some of these cross terms will
be of the type X1 times Xi or
X2 times X2.
These will be terms of this
form, and there is n of them.
And then we get cross terms,
such as X1 times X2, X1 times
X3, X2 times X1, and so on.
How many terms do
we have here?
Well, if we have n terms
multiplying n other terms we
have a total of n
squared terms.
n are already here, so the
remaining terms, which are the
cross terms, will be
n squared minus n.
Or, in a simpler form, it's
n times n minus 1.
So now how are we going to
calculate the expected value
of X squared?
Well, we will use linearity
of expectations.
So we need to calculate the
expected value of Xi squared,
and we also need to calculate
the expected value of Xi Xj
when i is different from j.
Let us start with Xi squared.
First, if we use the symmetric
description of our model, all
permutations are equally likely,
then all persons play
the same role.
There's symmetry
in the problem.
So Xi squared has the same
distribution as X1 squared.
Then, X1 is a 0-1 random
variable, a
Bernoulli random variable.
So X1 squared will always take
the same numerical value as
the random variable X1.
This is a very special case
which happens only because a
random variable takes
values in .
And 0 squared is
the same as 0.
1 squared is the same as 1.
This expected value is something
that we have already
calculated, and it is 1/n.
Let us now move to the
calculation of the expectation
of a typical term
inside the sum.
So let i be different than
j, and look at the
expected value of Xi Xj.
Once more, because of the
symmetry of the probabilistic
model, it doesn't matter which
i and j we are considering.
So we might as well consider
the product of X1 with X2.
Now, X1 and X2 take
values 0 and 1.
And the product of the two also
takes values 0 and 1.
So this is a Bernoulli random
variable, and so the
expectation of that random
variable is just the
probability that this random
variable is equal to 1.
But for the product to be equal
to 1, the only way that
this can happen is if both of
these random variables happen
to be equal to 1.
Let us now turn to
the sequential
description of the model.
The probability that the first
person gets their own hat back
and the second person gets
their own hat back is the
probability that the first one
gets their own hat back, and
then multiplied by the
conditional probability that
the second person gets their own
hat back, given that the
first person got their
own hat back.
What are these probabilities?
The probability that
a person gets their
own hat back is 1/n.
Given that person 1 got their
own hat back, person 2 is
faced with a situation
where there are n
minus 1 available hats.
And one of those is
that person's hat.
So the probability that person
2 will also pick his or her
own hat is 1 over n minus 1.
Now we are in a position to
calculate the expected value
of X squared.
The expected value of X squared
consists of the sum of
n expected values, each one of
which is equal to 1/n plus so
many expected values, because
we have so many terms, each
one of which, by this
calculation, is 1/n times 1
over n minus 1.
And we see that we get
cancellations here.
And we obtain 1 plus 1,
which is equal to 2.
On the other hand we have this
term that we need to subtract.
We found previously that
the expected value of
X is equal to 1.
So we need to subtract 1.
And the final answer to our
problem is that the variance
of X is also equal to 1.
So what we saw in this problem
is that we can deal with quite
complicated models, but by
breaking them down into more
manageable pieces, first break
down the random variable X as
a sum of different random
variables, then taking the
square of this and break it
down into a number of
different terms, and then by
considering one term at a
time, we can often end up with
the solutions or the answers
to problems that
would have been
otherwise quite difficult.